[Music]
today marks the 40th anniversary of
Elvis's death and while fans are
flocking to Graceland to pay tribute
Priscilla is with our nischelle Turner
as she remembers the man who would
forever be her King
we never thought he'd passed we just
never ever had that in my mind Elvis was
just 42 years old when he passed away in
the home he loved and it's still it's
still unbelievable because there was so
much a part of our lives
my life and my daughter's life that and
everyone around him last night Priscilla
and Elvis's daughter Lisa Marie helped
mourners like their candles at the
candlelight vigil by the Kings gravesite
Lisa Marie was with her son Benjamin who
looks a lot like his grandfather and her
eight-year-old twin daughters now they
hear his songs ago oh that's always
that's always love they loved that song
you know today Graceland is a successful
museum but when Elvis died his estate
was in financial trouble
it was Priscilla who decided to preserve
his legacy so he always had this dream
to keep Graceland absolutely and when I
was told that that we couldn't afford
the taxes income and state and that we
should probably sell it I said there's
no way we're going to do that and they
said that Elvis would be forgotten in
six months so I then had to roll up my
sleeves and go on a path of my own to
start finding help to uh to keep it a
private man when he was home in Memphis
these rare home movies off his daily
life are treasured by his family do you
never just go back and look and say aha
I forgot about that or yeah yeah I do
but we didn't really have that that many
because the whole movie is unlucky he
had given me a camera and he didn't
really like it just taken because so
many people would take pictures of him
we didn't have social media we didn't
have selfies I can't even imagine Elvis
doing a selfie it's just just not like
him
[Music]
Oh